consider the following statement human
beings only use 10% of their brain
capacity well as a neuroscientist I can
tell you that while Morgan Freeman
delivered this line with the gravitas
that makes him a great actor this
statement is entirely false the truth is
human beings use 100% of their brain
capacity the brain is a highly efficient
energy demanding organ that gets fully
utilized and even though it is at full
capacity being used it suffers from a
problem of information overload there's
far too much in the environment than it
can fully process so to solve this
problem of overload evolution devised a
solution which is the brains attention
system attention allows us to notice
select and direct the brains
computational resources to a subset of
all that's available we can think of
attention as the leader of the brain
wherever attention goes the rest of the
brain follows in some sense it's your
brains boss and over the last 15 years
I've been studying the human brains
attention system in all of our studies
I've been very interested in one
question if it is indeed the case that
our attention is the brains boss is it a
good boss does it actually guide us well
and to dig in on this big question I
wanted to know three things first how
does attention control our perception
second why does it fail us often leaving
us feeling foggy and distracted and
third can we do anything about this
fogginess can we train our brain to pay
better attention to have more strong and
stable attention in the work that we we
do in our lives so I wanted to give you
a brief glimpse into how we're gonna
look at this a very poignant example of
how our attention ends up getting
utilized and I want to do it using the
example of somebody that I know quite
well
he ends up being part of a very large
group of people that we work with for
whom attention is a matter of life and
death think of medical professionals or
firefighters or soldiers or Marines this
is the story of a marine captain captain
Jeff Davis and the scene that I'm going
to share with you as you can see is not
about his time in the battlefield he was
actually on a bridge in Florida but
instead of looking at the scenery around
him seeing the beautiful vistas and
noticing the cool ocean breezes he was
driving fast and contemplating driving
off that bridge and he would later tell
me that it took all of everything he had
not to do so you see he just returned
from Iraq and while his body was on that
bridge his mind his attention was
thousands of miles away
he was gripped with suffering his mind
was worried and preoccupied and had
stressful memories and really bred for
his future and I'm really glad that he
didn't take his life because he is a
leader knew that he wasn't the only one
that was probably suffering many of his
fellow Marines probably were too and in
the year 2008 he partnered with me in a
the first-of-its-kind project that
actually allowed us to test and offer
something called mindfulness training to
active duty military personnel but
before I tell you about what mindfulness
training is or the results of that study
I think it's important to understand how
attention works in the brain so what we
do in the laboratory is that many of our
studies of attention involve brainwave
recordings in these brainwave recordings
people were finally looking caps that
are sort of like swimming caps that have
electrodes embedded in them these
electrodes pick up the ongoing brain
electrical activity and they do it with
millisecond temporal precision so we can
see these small yet detectable voltage
fluctuations over time and doing this we
can very precisely plot the timing of
the brains activity about a hundred and
seventy milliseconds after we've shown
our research participants a face on the
screen
a very reliable detectable brain
signature it happens right at the back
of the scalp above the regions of the
brain that are involved in face
processing now this happens so reliably
and so on cue as the brains face
detector that we've even given this
brain wave component a name we call it
the n170 component and we use this
component in many of our studies it
allows us to see the impact that
attention may have on our perception so
I'm going to give you a sense of the
kind of experiments that we actually do
in the lab we would show participants
images like this one you should see a
face and a scene overlaid on each other
and what we do is we ask our
participants as they're viewing a series
of these types of overlaid images to do
something with their attention on some
trials we'll ask them to pay attention
to the face and to make sure they're
doing that we ask them to tell us by
pressing a button if the face appeared
to be male or female on other trials we
asked them to tell us what the scene was
was it indoor or outdoor and in this way
we can manipulate attention and confirm
that the participants were actually
doing what we said our hypotheses about
attention were as follows if attention
is indeed doing his job and affecting
perception maybe it works like an
amplifier and what I mean by this is
that when we direct attention to the
face it becomes clearer and more salient
right it's easier to see but when we
direct it to the scene the face becomes
barely perceptible as we process the
scene information so what we wanted to
do is look at this brainwave component
of face detection the n170 and see if it
changed at all as a function of where
our participants were paying attention
to the scene or the face and here's what
we found we found that when they paid
attention to the face the n170 was
larger and when they paid attention to
the scene as you can see in red it was
smaller and that gap you see between the
blue and red lines is pretty powerful
what it tells us is that attention which
is really the only thing that changed
since the images they viewed were
identical in both cases attention
changes perception and it does so
very fast within 170 milliseconds of
actually seeing a face in our follow-up
studies we wanted to look to see what
would happen how could we perturb or
diminish this effect and our hunch was
that if you give people or put people in
a very stressful environment if you
distract them with disturbing negative
images images of suffering and violence
sort of like what you might see on the
news unfortunately that doing this might
actually affect their attention and
that's indeed what we found if we
present stressful images while they're
doing this experiment this gap of
attention shrinks its power diminishes
so in some of our other studies we
wanted to see okay great not great
actually bad news that stress does this
to the brain but if it is the case that
stress has this powerful influence on
attention through external distraction
what if we don't need external
distraction what if we distract
ourselves and to do this we had to
basically come up with an experiment in
which we could have people generate
their own mind wandering this is having
off-task thoughts while we're engaged in
an ongoing task of some sort and the
trick to mind wandering is that
essentially you bore people so hopefully
there's not a lot of mind wandering
happening right now when we bore people
people happily generate all kinds of
internal content to occupy themselves
right so we devised what might be
considered one of the world's most
boring experiments all the participants
saw were series of faces on the screen
one after another they pressed the
button every time they saw the face that
was pretty much it
well the one trick was that sometimes
the face would be upside down and it
would happen very infrequently on those
trials they were told just to withhold
the response pretty soon we could tell
that they were successfully
mind-wandering because they pressed the
button when that face was upside down
even though it's quite plain to see but
it was upside down so we wanted to know
here what happens when people have
mind-wandering
and what we found was that very similar
to external stress and external
distraction in the environment internal
distraction our own mind wandering also
shrinks the gap of attention it
diminishes attentions power so what do
all of these studies tell us they tell
us that attention is very powerful in
terms of effect
our perception even though it's so
powerful it's also fragile and
vulnerable and things like stress and
mind wandering diminish its power but
that's all in the context of these very
controlled laboratory settings what
about in the real world what about in
our actual day-to-day life what about
now where is your attention right now to
kind of bring it back I'd like to make a
prediction about your attention for the
remainder of my talk you're up for it
here's the prediction you will be
unaware of what I'm saying for four out
of the next eight minutes it's a
challenge so pay attention please now
why am I saying this
I'm surely gonna assume that you're
gonna remain Steve seated and you know
grace graciously keep your eyes on me as
I speak but a growing body of literature
suggests that we mind wander we take our
mind away from the task at hand
about 50% of our waking moments these
might be small little trips that we take
away private thoughts that we have and
when this mind wandering happens it can
be problematic now I don't think
there'll be any dire consequences with
you all sitting here today but imagine a
military leader missing four minutes of
a military briefing or a judge missing
four minutes of testimony or a surgeon
or firefighter missing any time the
consequences in those cases could be
dire so one question we might ask is why
do we do this why do we mind wander so
much well part of the answer is that our
mind is an exquisite time-traveling
master it can actually time travel very
easily if we think of the mind sort of
at the metaphor of a music player we see
this we can rewind the mind to the past
to reflect on events that have already
happened right or we can go in fast
future to plan for the next thing that
we want to do and we land in this mental
time travel mode or the Pat of the past
or the future very frequently and we
land there often without our awareness
most times without our awareness even if
we want to be paying attention think of
just the last time we're trying to read
a book got to the bottom of the page
with no idea what the words were saying
right this happens to us and when this
happens when we mind wander without an
ax
that we're doing it there are
consequences we make errors we miss
critical information sometimes and we
have difficulty making decisions what's
worse is when we experience stress when
we're in a moment of overwhelm
we don't just reflect on the past when
we rewind where we end up being in the
past ruminating reliving or regretting
events that have already happened or
under stress we fast-forward the mind
not just a productively plan but we end
up catastrophizing or worrying about
about events that haven't happened yet
and frankly may never happen so at this
point you might be thinking to yourself
okay
mind wandering is happening a lot often
it happens without our awareness and
under stress it's even worse we mind
wandering more powerfully and more often
is there anything we can possibly do
about this and I'm happy to say the
answer is yes from our work we're
learning that the opposite of a stressed
and Montand wandering mind is a mindful
one mindfulness has to do with paying
attention to our present moment
experience with awareness and without
any kind of emotional reactivity of
what's happening it's about keeping that
button right on play to experience the
moment-to-moment
unfolding of our lives and mindfulness
is not just a concept it's more like
practice you have to embody this mindful
mode of being to have any benefits and a
lot of the work that we're doing we're
offering people programs that give our
participants a suite of exercises that
they should do daily in order to
cultivate more moments of mindfulness in
their life and for many of the groups
that we work with high-stress groups
like I said soldiers medical
professionals for them is that we know
that mind-wandering can be really dire
so we want to make sure we offer them
very accessible Lowe time constraints to
optimize the training so they can
benefit from it and when we do this what
we can do is track to see what happens
not just in their regular lives but when
we offer it in the most demanding
circumstances that they may have
why do we want to do this well we wanted
for example give it to students right
around final-season or we want to give
the training to accountants during tax
season or soldiers and Marines while
they're deploying why is that because
those are the moments that in which
their attention is most likely to be
vulnerable because of stress and
mind-wandering and those are also the
moments in which we want their attention
to be in peak shape so they can perform
well so what we do in our research is we
have them take a series of attention
tests so we track their attention at the
beginning of some kind of high stress
interval and then two months later we
track them again and we want to see if
there's a difference is there any
benefit of offering them mindfulness
training can we protect against the
lapse is an attention that might arise
over high stress so here's what we find
over a high stress interval
unfortunately the reality is if we don't
do anything at all attention declines
people are worse at the end of this high
stress interval than before but if we
offer mindfulness training we can
protect against this they stay stable
even though just like the other groups
they were experiencing high stress and
perhaps even more impressive is that if
people take our training programs over
let's say eight weeks and they fully
commit to doing the daily mindfulness
exercises that allow them to learn how
to be in a present moment in the present
moment well they actually get better
over time even though they're in high
stress and this last point is actually
important to realize because it suggests
to us is that mindfulness exercises are
very much like physical exercise if you
don't do it you don't benefit but if you
do engage in mindfulness practice the
more you do the more you benefit and I
want to just bring it back to captain
Jeff Davis as I mentioned to you at the
beginning his Marines were involved in
the very first project of that we ever
did in offering mindfulness training and
they showed this exact pattern which was
very heartening we had offered them the
mindfulness training right before they
were deployed to Iraq and upon their
return captain Davis shared with us what
he was feeling was the benefit of this
program he said that unlike last time
after this deployment there were much
more press
they were discerning they were not as
reactive and in some case they were
really more compassionate with the
people they were engaging with and each
other he said in many ways he felt that
the mindfulness training program we
offered gave them a really important
tool to protect against developing
post-traumatic stress disorder and even
allowing it to turn into post-traumatic
growth to us this was very compelling
and it ended up that captain Davis and I
you know this was about a decade ago in
2008 we've kept in touch all these years
and he himself has gone on to continue
practicing mindfulness in a in a daily
way he was promoted to major he actually
then ended up retiring from the Marine
Corps he went on to get a divorce to get
remarried to have a child to get an MBA
and through all of these challenges and
transitions and joys of his life he kept
up with his mindfulness practice and his
fate would have it just a few months ago
captain Davis suffered a massive heart
attack at the age of 46 and he ended up
calling me a few weeks ago and he said I
want to tell you something I know that
the doctors who worked on me they saved
my heart but mindfulness saved my life
the presence of mind I had to stop the
ambulance that ended up taking me to the
hospital himself the clarity of mind he
had to notice when there was fear and
anxiety happening but not be gripped by
it he said for me these were the gifts
of mindfulness and I was so relieved to
hear that he was okay but really
heartened to see that he had transformed
his own attention he one went from
having a really bad boss an attention
system that nearly drove him off a
bridge to one that was an exquisite
leader and died and saved his life so I
want to actually end by sharing my call
to action to all of you and here it is
pay attention to your attention all
right pay attention to your attention
and incorporate mindfulness training as
part of your daily wellness
in order to tame your own my wandering
mind and allow your attention to be a
trusted guide in your own life thank you
[Applause]
[Music]